MMA and stand up of both [ __ ] Arts
man I consider you an artist just like
me and MMA when when you fight five or
six times and I see the breakdown and
it's Brendan going well you know I'm not
worried about this Jiu Jitsu game
because my hand is right here that guy's
gonna lose because he didn't evolve
between training camps yeah he didn't go
to a Muay Thai place and go let me just
learn Muay Thai you know even if I take
just take a kick out and learn how to
distance my head I won't be getting
clipped these guys don't grow so from
watching MMA I learned what I had to do
to grow in between training camps you
always got to be learning doesn't mean
you have to be writing you have to be
doing experiencing different things I
think different perspectives different
perspectives so even though you have a
great Jiu Jitsu teacher in the in the
Gracie Brothers yeah you know what I'm
gonna go hang out we could bring you for
sure yeah he trains for Doom he's got to
be doing [ __ ] something right okay